what happened in the last case you were
with
Naro that was
good until it wasn't I wanted to start
with this story because like let's be
honest most people will always think of
you synonymously with Clarice darling so
to see you back the detective story is
like a completely wish fulfillment
moment but I wanted to ask you what do
you think it is about characters like
Liz and Clarice that really resonates
with audiences to the point where they
want to Journey with them as they try to
find the bad guys and maybe why you're
maybe particularly drawn back to this um
part of the genre I absolutely love Sans
of lambs I think it's an amazing movie a
classic and was a perfect script to
start with because it came from an
absolutely perfect novel um so I think
that's what we have in common is that we
have a really great scripts uh and in
that respect it's because we have two
fully complex female characters um
that's surprisingly rare I don't know
why but it is surprisingly rare that
being said I don't think think Clarice
and Liz have absolutely anything in
common besides the fact that they grew
up in a male dominated uh police kind of
World um the Clarice from the FBI but uh
and that may have impacted them
certainly Clarice is at the beginning of
her career and daners is at the end of
her career so we get to see kind of a
trajectory of possibility of where
Clarice could have ended up um but I I I
don't think there's any two characters
that are more different Clarice is like
a a good girl on the good path doing the
right thing very internalized she has
her very internalized trauma and uh Liz
Danvers is you know a rebellious
mean-spirited has terrible jokes lots of
Insidious internal bias um she's unself
realized and unconscious so she's uh
she's kind of on the opposite
Vector I wonder if that's where Clarice
ends up that's a depressing thought but
a realistic one in 20203 real talk yeah
good question one of the things like
silence lens I do think you also have is
an incredible person at the helm of it
this time it's with Issa Lopez and I
know that you are a copile director
filmmaker in your heart as well as an
actor one of my favorite memories of you
is the introduction that I watch
whenever I watch
lahen film um but I'm just curious what
Drew you to working with Issa and I pray
that it was a late night watching tigers
not afraid because that's what drew me
to her yeah I was very I didn't know of
the movie until I was told that she was
going to be directing the True Detective
franchise and and I read the script
loved it and thought like oh I can't
wait to meet this director saw her movie
was completely excited about meeting her
and
um uh we just had an immediate um
synchronicity I think uh I I think she's
my favorite director I've ever worked
with so she's it's not just that she's
intelligent Charming uh brilliant but
self-facing humble funny you know all
that stuff she's also like the first
person on the Dance Floor and um a hoot
to be around and maybe because we're
both over 40 ladies I'm a little more
over 40 than her but I think we
understand the complexity of these
female characters in a way that a lot of
other directors and actors wouldn't have
gotten to the other thing I actually
wanted to say with Issa too I'm glad
that you pointed that out because yeah
she's first one on the dance floor um
she's absolutely a riot but I will say
knowing that you guys probably had so
much fun outside of it I love that you
were able to sort of like make this
compelling story and I love the whole
one more case and then you and I are
done that you sort of give in this um to
Evangeline I would love for you to take
us inside that moment both as a an actor
like yourself working with someone like
Kaylee because I really feel like her
portrayal as Evangeline is just kind of
jaw-dropping Kaye Reese just the most
amazing actress uh five time world
champion boxer four or five times I
can't remember so many belts I can't
remember she has a quality that I've
really r barely ever seen a kind of
power that's just lives within her um
it's just how she was born uh and then
also to have this very
internalized sensitive uh vulnerability
that combination of those two things
what was really important for me was uh
understanding and shaking hands that
this film is about Navarro's journey and
uh is about that Central indigenous
grounded voice power of the indigenous
woman and and to see the world through
her point of view and to watch her
change and my character of Liz Danvers
is here to support that so we kind of
reverse engineered Liz Danvers in order
to make sure that all of her issues kind
of dovetailed shadowed mirrored the
issues that Navaro needed in order to
complete the Journey of the story um and
that's really refreshing for me because
you know I don't know about you but
there's a there is indigenous
representation out there but it's just
representation which is first part of
the equation but not the last part of
the equation and we really need to hear
indigenous voices be Central I love that
also I'm so going to tell eisa that
you're her favorite director I'm sure
she probably already knows that I can't
wait to be like girl you'll never guess
a Jodie Foster told me you the night
country it takes us
one by one this isn't going to be good
Kaye thank you so much I want to say
that I really enjoyed your performance
as evangelene and I cannot believe that
this was your first feature sort of like
job in Hollywood I cannot believe that
to begin with but having Jodie Foster as
a scene partner is probably the part of
it that I would just die so tell me when
you found that out and when you found
out you know you're going to be with
Clary Starling in a detective story oh
well thank you so much for watching I
appreciate that it was surreal I mean
it's just being it's like going to see p
may you know what I mean it's like the
master of the legend it was like
something that I'm really interested and
want to get into and really learn I mean
the universe provided and here I am with
this opportunity to be telling this
amazing story written by an amazing
director and writer and then being here
with jod farsa I fan girls for like 30
seconds but I had to you know keep my
composure that ring generalship that I
have in the boxing room I'm like yeah
what's going yeah I watched a few of
your movies you know but it was amazing
oh so you put your boxer mode on as a
way to sort of like guard you from the
fandom that's yeah yeah inside I'm
like hey I guess that's what you guys
got to do I mean obviously you are at
some point just actors on set and I'm
sure just like a you're always looking
for what's the other person doing so I
can maybe use that to improve did you
have those kinds of actor conversations
with jod or did she really sort of like
what did she sort of tell you about this
moment to sort of pay attention to
because she's you know her first film
was back when she was a teenager she
just has this Natural Curiosity to know
what's going on in everybody else's
brain how do you create she immediately
had this very supportive collaborative
type of energy it wasn't like I'm here
you're here you're the new beyond the it
wasn't it was I'm just here to support
and tell this story story and share
ideas and knock this down and learn from
you and I learned from you learned from
me and she was just so open and so
bright and excited to share her
knowledge and um she wonderful person
sense of humor is off the charart and
she was just very personable which made
it easier for me having all this
pressure being the new person and kind
of just watching her taking little tips
and how she deals with people and
circumstances is one big thing I took
from just her as a personality and so
talented and and educated and just um
very she has a very interesting brain I
I love um talking to her about anything
so funny that you mentioned Issa as this
incredibly talented you know writer
director at the center of your tail and
I will say this when you signed on to
the project she did not literally pull
any punches you have a lot of action in
this she's gonna make sure she gets all
of your sort of fight experience uh in
there how would you compare training for
this compared to what you're sort of
like doing in the ring obviously you
have the physicality obviously you can
do the moves but was it one of those
things where it's like you had to
unlearn some stuff or was it maybe just
an extension of what you feel you
already do well the endurance part of
being an athlete in the repetition and
training and preparing and also having
to be present no matter what you prepare
for is something I bring into acting and
I did have to kind of unlearn a few
things because you know I didn't want to
look like a boxer but I've been boxing
for over 20 years but it also helped for
me to be I'm very self-aware of my body
and physicality so I know you know where
things are distant wise and it also just
helped you know that's something I can
bring to the the table the acting table
that I have on one up on maybe some
other actors that have to work really
hard to get to the endurance or the the
discipline part of being an athlete as
well I would love for you to talk a
little bit more about e just her sort of
vibe on set one of the things jod said
which I thought was an incredible
compliment is she's the favorite
director that she's ever worked with and
she said that that was partially because
of the vibe that she put on set so I'd
love for you to give a peek inside of
what is the vibe of her set and and how
does that sort of help you guys as
actors she knows first of all she's an
amaz another amazing highly intelligent
uh woman that knows exactly what she
wants and her brain and her creativity
and Imagination is fascinating which
every word jumps off the page and I'm
like how do you come up with this stuff
but she's so passionate and excited to
share with the world and she wants to
create and she's so excited she calls
herself a geek um it's so funny but it
was fascinating to see how she can get
what she needs and wants out of people
in all different types of ways the vibe
on set was always happy Hi H it it
wasn't it was we all had our job to do
we all were in it together and she's
just so I I look up and admire her so so
much um it's like do you ever sleep
woman cuz I would be in the gym before
after we work and so wouldn't she so she
is um a Powerhouse but it was another
she had she handed me over at Navaro
with all this trust and I just wanted to
do the same thing and just do the best I
could um so knowing we had a trust of
one another and it was such a
comfortable environment in such an
uncomfortable environment put it that
way weather conditions that's said say
I'm thinking
stuff bad
stuff I
know I feel too Isa first of all
congratulations to think of us on a
stage at Fantastic Fest talking about
tires are not afraid to now here girly
I'm so excited about it but I have to
talk to you about joining this project
obviously a dream but then the idea that
you're going to be directing one of our
Supreme sort of like cinematic
detectives in Jody Foster and then also
being able to tell this story that I
know you spent a long time sort of
investigating exactly how you wanted to
explore a new detective story with these
types of characters yes I mean it's a
dream come true truly you know as a fan
girl myself as a geek um who watched the
series and loved it and missed the
feeling that it gave so did gave sa that
first um season and get the question
from HB of what would you do with this
he was like seriously I have ideas I
have ideas so and then go and think
about how could you infuse it with the
thing and how could you infuse it with
uh Unsolved Mysteries that every geek
loves like the de love pass and the
Marie Celeste and um and then um when
they said we're listening I went back
and I rewatched this first season and I
saw that the massive influences it felt
really like seven it made me feel like
seven so I rewatch seven which holds
amazingly seven in itself is a season of
True Detective seven itself would have
never been born without the Silence of
the lamps so I go and I watch that and
honestly that's the origin of all the
subgenre of creepy serial killers with
the Meed minds and um and I thought
let's have Jodie Foster you know it's uh
she's she's how this all started and she
was magnificent in that as she has been
in many things but we don't see her as
often as we want and we've never seen
her for several episodes of a whole
series you know so what a luxury so I
wrote this with her in mind and um and
when he she said yes I simply couldn't
believe it it was a dream come true and
uh and here we are I love this so much
um will say the fact that you also got
her to sign up um knowing that you were
going to be shooting in some very rough
conditions I think is a bigger Testament
because this is not the south of France
where she's kicking it most of the time
so talk about setting the feature in
Alaska and really sort of how you guys
then shot it in Iceland and what you
felt that really added to the narrative
and how early did you put that into the
scripts I think that was possibly the
first thing I wrote the very first line
I wrote thinking of of this story was a
wor turn in the ice
and so the I was there already and the
moment that you think about True
Detective it is a piece of Americana a
really really twisted dark Sinister
piece of Americana and uh and the i in
America is the Arctic and the only place
where you can find it like that is
Alaska so I decided to learn more about
this communities in Northwest Alaska
where the Night Comes and doesn't go
away for months and I learned a lot I
learned that 70% of the population there
is Inu and that there are Arctic
research stations NE next to it and uh
and I started to piece together the
elements that would create this story um
I went when I started working on this we
were in the middle of the pandemic and
lockdown and I couldn't go to Alaska so
I had to go to Alaska as best I could
through social media and through
listening to the radio stations and
through research but the the moment that
I could jump on a plane and go to Alaska
I did and uh and I went to the
communities and the towns that inspired
my fictional ANS and uh and I wish we
could have shot there but the truth is
uh during the winter which is when we
need to shoot there there is no roads
you cannot come by sea the sea freezes
and planes are subject to the winds so
it was Unthinkable to shoot here and uh
and so we went on a h of
what uh town north of the Arctic Circle
could give us the same landscape Iceland
has a thriving Film Community and uh
experienced cruise and offer those an
incredible tax credit and honestly rikic
is lovely and they have really good food
and really good music and I like this is
it and I think that was part of of of
the charm of bringing jod Foster on
board she loves the Eyes by the way she
she's experienced skier she was ready
for it in ways that I was not certainly
but um the next challenge was how to
reproduce that
Alaska that Al those those Alaskan towns
and the clothes and the food and
everything in Scandinavia so there was a
lot of cooperation with the Alaskan
communities and our supervisors and our
producers in Alaska to make it real I
love that well I have to get out of here
now I we will talk longer about this as
we get close to all the Emmys but I have
to leave you with this Jody Foster told
me that you are her favorite director
that she has ever worked with and I just
girl put that on a book somewhere get it
yeah no I'm going to I need to make a
clip of that and use it as my alarm in
the mornings that's what I'm going to
do